yeah well i mean just to be completely
straightforward with you
yeah i've been smoking for like four or
five days like
i was this was put putting for me as a
possibility this morning
and my inclination is [ __ ] like truth
i want the truth but
it also is true that i work for the city
of los angeles and i'm supposed to be
there right now
like in this whole week in fact and i'm
not
and all of a sudden here i am like yeah
but we don't we don't know when this is
being shot
we could have shot this back in november
yeah i'm inclined to just do it and yeah
it's the truth and it's the truth one
thing i hate is the lying
about what about who i am well let's see
how truthful we can be here
all right so patrick yeah uh where are
you from emerging where'd you grow up
i grew up in la verne california and
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young
yeah my parents divorced uh i think when
i was like four or five years old
but both of them were great
relationships with both of them always
to this day
uh lived with my mom until high school
and then my dad my dad's like philosophy
was that
boys need their their dad in high school
so we moved in with my dad
so i live with my mom and then my dad uh
it seems like it was a like i was even
feeling bad reading some of like the
other stories like
i don't have like like i don't have
these like overcoming things you know
like that i had to overcome for this
we had a lot of like freedom like low
accountability
uh especially in high school you know we
were just kind of allowed to do
whatever and start drinking drinking and
partying that uh
what kind of stuff good high school what
kind of kid were you in high school
good students like valedictorian level
almost you know like pretty good
really good did you go to college i went
to college straight out of high school
clear the claremont colleges uh
bombed out like start like develop the
crack addiction
uh during that time and uh
so dropped out went from like straight
a's to dropping out
and uh that started a a
string of attempts to go back to college
i was always very smart gifted
that i finally wound up doing in my 30s
at harvard
you went to harvard yeah and what did
you study
i studied history at harvard rather
randomly
so i was living in new england during my
like from age 25 to
33 uh just constantly in rehab
constantly like all the time and i was
with a i was in an
organization called teen challenge
that's uh
like a hardcore christian rehab and i
would uh
do great and like stay on and work on
staff relapse
and that that eventually led me there
because california like couldn't like
start me anymore i like
uh and i was just there i was doing i
was enjoying life working there and
randomly
at a church service a woman came up to
me and asked if i was a good student
randomly and i said yeah that's how i
get a's or f's
depending on how i'm doing and uh she
said harvard extension school
like it's like it's like harvard you
know for people that are like
like career age that go back to like a
school at night so i went looked it up
got in i was i didn't know if i was
gonna hang totally hung like
did well there and studied history what
is the difference between your
what would what will what will separate
an
a or an f for you i either get a's or
i'm not there
you don't care oh no i want crack oh
is it crack that's your oh yeah
everything all the what you're gonna
hear me say
like the the bad is crack hinges on
correct i want crack
and crack start a few at what age okay
so cracks are for me
geez uh i think 19 or 20.
but you'll so what led me to crack
was prostitutes and i don't really even
know why
i was uh so sort of like
intrigued by prostitutes as a
as a thing as a you know as a
uh as a thing that was out there and i
remember
literally like a friend of mine in high
school that his cousin would take him
like bowling on saturday nights and they
would go down the prostitute boulevards
of pomona
just to like yell at them and like it
was like a funny thing
and i heard that and my brain's like
prostitutes and
uh i started going down to i lived in
laverne i don't know if you're familiar
with that area
so femona is a crack especially in the
90s this is like the 90s
and yeah my girlfriend was a captain of
cheerleaders you know i'd be like
totally
and then something i'd want to go down
there too and i went down there
and i started going down there regularly
and they're smoking crack
i i hit a crack pipe probably a several
times probably four or five times
without knowing that never having heard
of crack existing as a thing i didn't
know there was anything called crack i
didn't know anything about drugs
and uh hit the crackpot because i was
with them and then finally one time
i hit it right and
immediately now i told her let's go get
more of this immediately
and uh from then it started being more
about the crack
than the the prostitutes
damn here we go so drugs have been
on and off issue for you for a long time
on and off but like
the major issue in my life you know so
are you married with kids or anything
like that no no
i'm 42 single
because of crack you know like all that
would be there yeah
are you working so uh
yeah i i have a job
i don't know what's going to happen with
it because i do the same thing every
time i smell crack
which is i mean it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable
like i don't sleep i don't stop i spend
every dollar i'll spend
i don't know you said see how honest we
could be you know like
i'll spend 15 20 grand
in a month in a month yeah like like
right now so i had seven months sober
on christmas night right what is it
what's it right now january 5th 37th i
think
okay and then you know like
the pullback is prostitutes right but uh
if i'm gonna go get a prostitute and i'm
sober i'm not gonna go to figaro or i'm
not gonna come here
i'm gonna go to like where you pay like
you know
way more and it's like you know someone
like in a hotel like an escort you know
i mean like
uh but i would do that and
like something would just bring me down
there something about
having the connection of like the two
things together
you know the crack and figaro you can
get crack and a girl
right the girl so yeah like having a
girl
that smokes crack too um
it's really sick it's a really like it's
like a fantasy
that oh man like
it's disgusting like i can like i don't
even know why
i'm so willing to sit here and talk
about it to
to sometimes sometimes it's cleansing
and healing well yeah that is what i've
been thinking today like
you know like um
i told a lot of people that i've
interviewed have said i haven't used
since i did that interview with you
really not not a majority but more than
a handful have come back and said
stay in touch with me because that would
be amazing uh
i mean i i know for sure i'm going to
use after this interview but like like
i didn't like have you ever been as
lewis one of the gentlemen that i use
another big job
he says just tell on yourself the more
you tell on yourself the more
like i am a tail on yourself sort of
person like like sometimes i don't know
what they call like an over sharer
you know and that's part of the
self-centeredness of the disease of
addiction
um i actually know quite a bit about the
disease of addiction which
doesn't really occur to me much when i'm
smoking in it
uh i think you're interested a little
bit of the sexual piece
like so that part of it is
it is what it is but like like sort of
evolved over time to where
first of all crack's terrible like as
far as drugs go if you want to feel good
like every drug is better than crack i
don't know if you've ever done drugs you
smoke weed
you smoke weed better than crack drink
better than crack like
crack's awful right but the one thing it
does is when you just
take that hit um for what it does for me
it's a extreme intense feeling of
euphoria and desire for sex and a
fantasy sort of like
mentality towards it you know so like
uh like i want
the closest female to be giving me oral
sex immediately at that at that point
um and then on the flip side it's pretty
much impossible for that to work
because of the physical thing of crack
you know i can't get an erection
but that's what i want and it's like
insatiable
um like it'll be common for me to be in
a hotel room by myself with
always with pornography watch porn like
constantly non-stop when i'm on a crack
binge
never watch porn even for one minute
when i'm when i'm sober don't even occur
to me
um and i'll take the first crack hit
and i'll be so convinced that like the
nearest woman wants to like have a porn
scene with me
that i like literally walk out of the
motel in my underwear and just scan the
parking lot
to see if there's a woman there because
i'll believe like the fancy's that deep
so this is disgusting this is this is
the real thing this is correct
it's across that's crack that's crack
and uh
so so yeah i do do that um
you know try to try to time it like take
that hit and go
and so that's where like the money gets
super stupid
because like i take a hit crack and
money's no it doesn't matter you know
like how much take it all
you know take it all to do what i want
because i
just don't have control is it destroying
your life it sounds like it's pretty
destructive
horribly destructive horribly
destructive so there's that part
um yeah so
you know i i was in teen challenge for
you know like seven eight years and you
know you relapse in a christian ministry
program where you're like
up the ladder uh you know you lose your
your your salary your place of living
you know it's
so i finally decided after like being
shipped to puerto rico and
doing teen challenge for a year there to
uh
to come back to la and uh just
get a job like get a regular job where
you know like
my mentality at that point was like you
know if i [ __ ] up
and relapse well my job's not going to
fire me
you know like i'm not going to lose my
apartment you know what i mean
not that night you know like teen
challenge and then you can keep
keep trying so yeah got hired by the
city of la
six years ago um and like it's a really
good job especially for a crack addict
you know
i always like to put myself down like
like i have the best job of all the
crack addicts that are
on their first day in narcotics
anonymous but the worst job of anyone
that graduated from harvard
you know but it's a good it's a good c
job it's a great people
it's engineering uh i you know i have a
great brain
i got i got a really great i know i do i
have a great brain and like the worst
addition of all time so
what do you think this is what's the
core of it
is it something that happened in your
childhood is it low self-worth is it
just an addictive
gene in your body i mean it's
i mean all the above not in that
childhood i mean i i
molested because it was like they were
like 10 11
12 year old girls and i was like four
five and they were just like
wanting me to do sex stuff you know and
i was just a little boy
and i didn't even think of that until
like several years of uh
you know i've probably been to rehab a
million times uh
then the binges are getting more and
more
you know like i like this really sucks
that i'm high right now and
and uh you know like the last time i
went on a really bad one
these last couple times it's like i
haven't really felt it this time yet but
it's like just like like like for
example like
this this came up you know someone like
pulled a gun on me like during my last
binge you know like a like but you know
i don't even know he
and i was absolutely like not even a
little bit scared
and i told him like what's that like you
[ __ ] do me a favor
you know because it's like so
destructive uh
you know like i i finally came clean at
work after
after having you know i'll go take a hit
then it's off then it's like a weekend
then it's like missing the next
couple days of the next week that might
show up you know i'll get back there
like on wednesday
and then literally wednesday night be
gone for for six weeks
gone and like what i'm doing for that as
much of that time as possible
and especially in the beginning is
smoking crack
like not caring ignoring everything can
i ask you to take the shoes off just
because they're making so much noise
so so the the body movements
jesus i wonder how much this video is
going to affect my life
the body movements this is like uh this
is like typical day four
i'm just doing nothing but smoke crack
cover crack down you bounce around
are you eating at all sleeping no sleep
um let me let me try to give you just an
idea of a binge
uh i came home from lake havasu where my
mom lives i was actually happy
because i got through thanksgiving and
christmas this year for the first time
since 2016. it's like i always relapse
in november
and coming back from a really relapse is
just
you know going back to work it used to
be always pretending
the last time i was the last time i did
it though i got honest at work
i felt really good about that so
come back christmas and whatever happens
i
you know like uh you know whatever the
stupid idea was like
i know i know people now down there
because i'm not i used to like start
with like a random person on the street
and that would just be awful
you know this time it's like a girl like
i'm friends with and
just decided to go for it like i went
down there and
you know lasted around and she she
called me and
you know we got you know i don't know
100 for the crack and
you're not going to go to the atm pull
out 500 000
and so that was
uh like december 25
i think it was a friday and by wednesday
morning
still awake i'm burnt out out of money
and uh i wind up going home
and sleeping and and not going out for
the rest of that week and uh
telling work now i have to tell work you
know like it's like
i'm i'm not there because i'm smoking
crack basically i don't say that but
that's what
you know i'm not gonna lie especially
when they all know and
i hate lying so but but it was like okay
we could like come back to work on i
work tuesday through saturday so i come
back to work on tuesday you know like
that's it and you know this could be
okay and
after the last after the last uh binge
we made a couple adjustments to the
money where i couldn't
uh it wasn't just all coming to me you
know just to try to like
sort of manage and uh so being back to
work tuesday which was
was three days ago and uh
on monday like i need to get a haircut i
need to get my car washed i need you
know i like to feel good
my paychecks go to my dad you know and
then like i always have like whatever i
need
ben mows it to me and my poor dad man
here's the thing about addiction though
i was not i was like
like i did my budget you know like okay
how much i
just for the record because i did that
crunch the numbers i spent
four thousand like 250 on
the december 25 through 29 4
250 don't tell them not there yeah
um just everything must go
it's like like convinced my dad just you
gonna send it i'll pay the bills i'm
gonna
i gotta go to work tomorrow you know
this seems to be 3 500 bucks your
parents know you have an addiction
problem oh yeah 100 they know everything
yeah yeah and if you weren't a crack
addict you probably wouldn't be going
down to figaro or wherever
anyway right i wouldn't you wouldn't no
yeah
oh no like just just to get a prostitute
oh
probably not no pretty much all the
tricks i've talked to drugs
come into the picture yeah there's a
whole section to figure out where
they're they don't smoke they don't uh
actually i went exploring that last
night with a guy i met
what part is that the northern part so
like you could tell
you could tell with girls yeah i
wouldn't be interested in that
you know you want the girls who are i
want you know i want to just get high
and
be crazy or like go like escort or what
i really want is like get some
self-esteem and get a girlfriend a wife
and all that but
that comes and you know that comes
being sober long-term and i haven't been
able to get past a year
so like literally you know and like it's
just the worst
behavior the most like just
i don't care it's like so selfish and
i'm like still numb to that i know
that's real
you know but like yeah give me the 3 500
we're good
and i've heard you're one of the most
loved uh tricks on figure out
you take care of the girls nicely i
assume well
yeah i do and it's like partially
uh lack of control
like oh that feels so good just keep
doing you know so yeah there's like
it's like that's not how you it's too
much you know it's too much but i also
like i'm also very generous you know
like i'm out here yeah everybody smoke
you know i want people to love me
because i don't like because i don't
love me
you know so um but there's a lot of ways
to think about it you know like
i have a job at least for the moment
that like a six-figure salary job
and i roll up down to uh where people
are like homeless
and you know just like want smoke and
gotta pay the rent and all that
and like i try you know
but sometimes i feel like it's sort of
like a slap in the face
you know like here i am ready to go
raise
ready to like go max you know and you
know
what i mean and there's a lot around
that but
mostly it's lack of control but yeah i'm
generous i'm nice um
like like what i want
while i'm smoking crack sexually is like
what's the word it's like
it's unattractive well not unattractive
without everybody
it's very like it's a very demanding ask
it's like kind of gross
it's you know what i mean it's like it's
something that like 95 women would be
disgusted by let's put it that way
what you're requesting them to do yeah
like i'm gonna i want to lay down in a
hotel room and smoke crack
while you give me well you give me a
head you know why you give me a blow job
and i want it to be awesome and my
opinions are gonna be limp
the whole time and like it's just kind
of like gross you know it's not like
that's how sex is supposed to be you
know between a man and a woman
and so that's what i want like that's
what i really want
and so like my approach has become like
you you you want to not be
erect when you're doing no no no not
that i wish i would i wish i could
confuse what you want i want that i want
someone to do that
like that's what i want the activity to
be he's going crack
getting getting like a like an awesome
[ __ ] yeah
it's probably pretty common down there
it's it's
to like have it be like to have it
actually feel good
it's like very it's quite rare and it's
uh
and it can't be demanded and so i don't
like basically what i'm
hoping to run into is like someone
that's actually going to enjoy
themselves
like hanging out and getting high and
then
and then yeah that's where that's where
i'm willing to you know be generous and
that's so disgusting man but but the
majority of like people that you're
trying to try to solicit
um won't be like into that
or it won't or or they'll say they are
but they won't be and it won't feel good
and i'd rather just like not even do it
honestly then
sort of like like force them to do you
been to rehabs and stuff like that [ __ ]
yeah where do you see your life going in
in 10 20 years do you think you'll still
be doing this
oh my god i mean just it'll kill you
yeah again i don't that'd be
that'd be a relief like this is like
i could say if you talk about it in a
way that makes it sound like
less ah you're kind of
talking about as if it's just a crazy
weekend you're having but yeah but i'm
describing it like uh
like an entertaining account you know
like like check out this story you know
like
oh my story you know but really what it
is is the most
i mean the words came to describe it you
know i talk about always the uh
the first wake up after a crack [ __ ]
the first wake up
where it's like you wake up
for like first two seconds waking up
after that it's like normal wake up like
i wake up every day work there and drink
coffee
go to work and then a couple seconds in
it's like oh this is different
oh yeah i like just blew off everything
i said [ __ ] you to everybody
like my phone right here with all kinds
of like normal people that love me
it's just being ignored ignored
and i'm right here the next cracker the
next crack
the next crack hit and like it's the
most
embarrassing embarrassing it's just
indescribable
so this is your day four yeah so like
is this the end of it or something
monday night knowing that i had to go to
work tuesday
and you know i wind up smoking crack
you're heading into a weekend here is
that going to make it like
like a 7-8 day i'm going to run out of
money
i'm going to probably run out of money
today you know oh [ __ ] i'm going to give
you money now though
you're going to burn it all on crack nah
yeah but i won't it won't be yeah but it
won't make it i feel like i feel like
i'll
i'll hold off on giving you money and
i'll see you in a week or three
that's cool i'm not going to do that
just to protect you from some more
self-destruction
yeah i won't it won't protect me like
the difference between
i don't know i don't even know how much
you're planning on giving me but that's
gonna be an insignificant figure
you're gonna figure it out yeah like
there's i mean this is gonna be it
though whether everybody's gonna be a
thousand
not nothing close to that right we'll
see oh [ __ ] okay well
we could talk about that we want to do
something like i did when she told me
you're gonna pay me anything i was
surprised honestly when amber told me
that this morning well i mean you're not
gonna come out here and talk like this
for free yeah well that's that's fair
yeah actually [ __ ] see yeah you see how
this works yeah well you know but then
but i don't want you just to burn at all
why
because you're just like i'm
contributing to your self-destruction or
not
you're gonna you're gonna argue at that
point strong no no i'll be like
i'm not gonna are you trying to get the
money out of you it's really like no i
just i just don't want to contribute to
you
no i mean like it's it's uh it's
it's at least at least i did i like did
something for this part of the money and
said you're
you're incredibly honest i'll tell you
that wow um
so yeah so like so uh
so i go ahead and i split crack you know
what's funny is that i went and picked
up a crazy girl it's like like last
binge back
like in may i got into methamphetamine
like like way more than
ever and got into some methamphetamine
people and so
like here's another thing about it i'm
sitting at a motel room
smoking crack watching porn non-stop no
sleep
like now drive around like like i think
like
i just like driving like from south
central up to
i had a motel in alhambra or
um just like the mexican ladies walking
up the street to buy the groceries i'm
like
checking out each of them you know just
sick in my head because of all that
and um okay
i'm kind of rambling so there's this
there was this girl
that was like a fantasy girl when i met
her in may
that was like it's like beautiful you
know like
young hispanic like just beautiful
and like i'm supposed to crack this
pokemon like let me let's
let's let that happen somehow which
would like almost never happen like it's
like
i'm like out there like you know uh
closing the deal um that girl winds up
being
like just the poor thing like i would
remind psychosis
i don't remember talking to talking to
think like unreal invisible things
like a five-year-old right hung out with
everyone it was crazy so i decided
monday night instead of you know i don't
wanna get high i gotta work tomorrow
i'm to go because she texts me all the
time like oh my god i want to see you
again i miss you
she's like a child she's just like i go
and pick her up i decide that's the
thing i'm going to do
and maybe like maybe i'll smoke a little
meth but then i'll be able to go to work
tomorrow
just delusion and i went picked her up
she was still equally crazy as last time
immediately we got a room in whittier
and then i'm like you know what i'm
gonna go downtown get some crack
and monday night did that by tuesday
morning
i'm in my apartment you know like the
first day of a crack bench where i'm
just scared
scared of anything um and i text
my work i'm not gonna make it you know
i'm not gonna make it and that's the
last thing i said to him
that was tuesday morning so
yes it's you haven't lost that job yet i
haven't lost that job yet
i have not lost that job yet but it's
like what do what do you think most
people don't understand about addiction
people that don't use
like the lack of choice in it which that
kind of sounds like a [ __ ] move you
know like
you're certainly intelligent enough to
know better but it's not about
intelligence right so like
okay yeah like even like with no sleep
and everything you
like yeah i here's the thing
i know exactly what's going to happen
like i know if i take this hit i'm
[ __ ] canning like really bad for six
weeks i'm gonna hate myself and i'm
gonna want to die i started wanting to
die the last
then like really you know like like kind
of changing my views about death
being a negative thing you know and
i do it anyway so
like the whole idea that oh you know you
can just uh
just don't do it just just man up uh
for a real addict i think that's not uh
that's
that's what the broken part is is the
mental thing that does that
um but
you know like i'm really i was really
heavily believing
i still maybe would do will um in the 12
steps
i like i somehow went old school
alcoholics anonymous
like straight from the book it was
loving it and like for the first time
ever without really like
it just like sort of evolved into a
thing it's like you know the
the hour the god part like it has to be
god like i have a mental thing that only
a
supernatural thing can break and like
these steps are the way to do that
and you know i literally like missed
like maybe one or two days and seven
months of
you know 4 30 a.m to like 5 45
prayer meditation feeling great doing
the whole thing
and here we are you know so
you know my sponsor can i read something
he he texted me
i don't know why i've been reading this
to people when he texted this to me i
cried
and uh a little bit oh [ __ ] hold on
as i'm talking about crack the the
various crack uh
sort of hustling is going on outside
okay with george here i've read this to
a couple of people doesn't seem like
you know so i talked to him and this is
like in between the two relapses he said
patrick it's not a big deal
i know it feels like it is but that's
you in the grand scheme of things
you're a child of god and being so
incredibly human that he probably loves
it
well i hit me you know like i
you know i became christian through teen
challenge and
i've i know i like
i can say like i know that that's real i
don't know what you believe about that
but
jesus christ is god like i know that's
real um
you know and
why do i have the shittiest addiction of
any human ever
there's a question that maybe you all
know the answer to someday
um you know but like right now
like this is another thing i realized
it's so
so like thoroughly like
every like so it like just thoroughly
inconsiderate and egregious in every way
to every person
like and with no hiding
uh and like the payoff that i get for
that
i realized is being able to keep smoking
like this part of just being as high as
i can be
uh that's the antidote for that feeling
just take another crack
taking the crack it take another crack
it taking the crack it
so i don't know what's going to happen
like ah there's a little bit of
momentum brewing from here and there uh
of like losing the job and like being
like like down here you know maybe down
here
maybe that's what it takes you know for
for me
uh like i don't say i don't like
don't i'm not scared of that you know
like
like i even think like you know for me
you know because i like
you know i i become a real pretender
like you'll see me you'll think
to go to have to go from whatever to
have it be such a huge
swing right huge swing and so
irresponsible you know like
versus like someone that just does crack
or does drugs or does it as a lifestyle
and adapts to the to the
to the day-to-day whatever that winds up
being i wonder i don't want to do this
but i wonder
how shitty that would be if it would be
shittier than
than this you know what i mean shittier
than pretending i'm a
civil engineer when really i'm a
crackhead yeah i guess i signed up to
take the civil engineering
professional engineering test on january
26th
i already paid for it i was like i was
uh
i was doing good on the studying you
know i was getting like excited like i'm
gonna pass i'm not gonna tell anybody
where i'm taking up and pass it
i'm probably not gonna pass it actually
still might but probably not i'm not in
this state yeah not in this state i mean
yeah i don't know i mean hopefully i get
clean and
it sticks but how could i keep i know
like it's like i tell the statistics you
know like i gotta be great but like what
do the statistics say what's gonna
happen what happens every time
that's that's addiction that's the
direction you asked earlier what do
people not understand
like the disease of addiction means you
have to use like it's going to happen
it's not if it's when
that's the disease that's real addiction
so
yeah all right patrick thank you so much
for
being so honest yeah this is
this is a blur give me something like uh